>> Laura: WE'VE GOT TO GO.
THANK YOU.
GREAT SEGMENT.
MARK THE TAPE.
I WANT THAT SOUND BITE.
REMEMBER WHEN THE FEARMONGERING
ON THE LEFT WARNED US THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD ISOLATE US
FROM THE WORLD?
THAT WE WOULD HAVE NO FRIENDS.
INSTEAD WHAT WE HAVE WITNESSED
HIS GROWING ALLIANCES WITH
LEADERS SUCH AS FRENCH
PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MACRON AND HE
IS THE GUEST OF HONOR AT THE
PRESIDENT'S FIRST STATE DINNER
TOMORROW NIGHT.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS AND OTHER
ISSUES WITH WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY HOGAN GIDLEY.
DELIGHTED HE'S WITH US.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
I WANT EVERYONE TO SEE THAT
HOGAN HAS AN ACTUAL JOURNAL.
I MEAN, I LOVE THAT.
YOU HAVE AN ACTUAL BOOK.
NOT A LAPTOP.
YOU ARE WRITING DOWN LIKE A REAL
OLD-SCHOOL, SOMEONE PREPARING.
I LOVE THAT.
I MISS IT.
I HOPE YOU'RE TAKING NOTES.
TELL ME ABOUT THIS MACRON
RELATIONSHIP.
I LOVE IT.
THEY WERE ALL TRASHING TRUMP
BECAUSE HE WAS GOING TO OFFEND
THE WORLD.
NOW THE WORLD WANTS TO COME HERE
AND MEET HIM.
>> THEY THOUGHT THE BARACK OBAMA
APOLOGY TOUR WAS THE WAY TO GET
FRIENDS AND ALLIES.
TURNS OUT IT'S THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
HE IS GROWING RELATIONSHIPS.
FRANCE HAS BEEN WITH US FOREVER.
ONE OF THE FIRST TRADE DEALS WE
EVER DID QUITE FRANKLY WAS AFTER
WE SIGNED THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE.
IT WAS WITH FRANCE.
HE HAS ONLY GONE TO MAKE THIS
BIGGER AND BETTER.
THEY ARE CLOSE FRIENDS.
THEY TALK ALL THE TIME.
THEIR RELATIONSHIP COULDN'T BE
BETTER.
>> Laura: THIS IS
"THE HUFFINGTON POST" HEADLINE
IN NOVEMBER.
YOU'RE GOING TO LOVE THIS.
LET'S LOOK AT IT.
IT ONLY TOOK TRUMP ONE YEAR TO
TRASH AMERICA'S GLOBAL
REPUTATION.
THE "LOS ANGELES TIMES," MAY 8,
2017.
FRANCE'S ELECTION PROVES AMERICA
HAS AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT NOT TO DO
HAS AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT NOT TO D
DO.
NO ONE EVER BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE
ON THIS STUFF.
WE HAD THIS ONGOING, YEAH, OKAY.
A NEVER-TRUMPER WROTE THAT.
>> A SELF-LOATHING REPUBLICAN.
>> THEY'RE NOT REPUBLICANS.
THEY NEVER REALLY WERE.
THE SO-CALLED EXPERTS WERE WRONG
BEFORE THE ELECTION AND NOT WHO
THEY ARE AGAIN.
AND THEY JUST KEEP -- THEY KEEP
HAVING GIGS ON TV, COLUMNS AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
"WASHINGTON POST."
THIS RELATIONSHIP WITH MACRON,
HE'S AN INTERESTING CAT FOR
TRUMP TO BE A PAL WITH.
HE'S KIND OF PUTTING THE SIGNAL
UP FOR THE MOVE IN FRANCE TO PUT
EXPEDITED PROCESS ON REMOVAL,
DEPORTATION OF IMMIGRANTS AND
FANS -- IN FRANCE.
HE'S NOT A POPULIST LIKE TRUMP.
HE IS MORE OF A GLOBALIST,
IMMODERATE GLOBALISTS.
HOW DO THEY HAVE THIS PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP?
>> THERE ARE SOME SIMILARITIES.
YOU HEARD MACRON MAKE THE
COMMENT THAT HE USED THE PHRASE
MAKE FRANCE GREAT AGAIN, HE USED
IT THE OTHER DAY.
>> Laura: WITH THE FLOOD OF
MIGRANTS?
FROM GERMANY?
>> THEY WERE BOTH FORMER
BUSINESSMEN.
NO ONE THOUGHT THEY COULD WIN
THIS ELECTION.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY.
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE THEY
DON'T AGREE.
THE PARIS CLIMATE DEAL.
THEY DON'T AGREE ON THE IRAN
DEAL.
THE PRESIDENT IS ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED.
>> Laura: THE EUROPEAN TRADE
DEAL WHICH TRUMP DOESN'T WANT.
>> THERE ARE MAJOR DIFFERENCES
BUT THEY HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP.
CLOSE PERSONAL FRIENDS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID TODAY WE ARE
HE'S A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE.
THEY HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP.
>> Laura: MACRON WANTS THE
PRESIDENT TO STAY IN SYRIA
LONGER.
UNTIL ISIS IS CRUSHED.
THE PRESIDENTS INSTINCT AND WHAT
HE CAMPAIGNED ON IS THAT AMERICA
IS NOT GOING TO STAY BOGGED DOWN
IN THESE PLACES WHERE WE HAVE NO
REAL POLITICAL SOLUTION,
MILITARY SOLUTION, EXCUSE ME.
WILL THE RELATIONSHIP HAVE AN
EFFECT ON THE PRESIDENT'S
ULTIMATE DECISION TO STAY IN
SYRIA.
EVERYTHING WE KNOW ABOUT
FRANCE'S RELATIONSHIP, SENDING
TECHNOLOGY TO RUSSIA AND THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH IRAN.
NOT THAT --
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
WORRIED ABOUT WHEN TRUMP TOOK
OVER AS THE PRESIDENT, THAT
WASHINGTON, D.C., WOULD SHAKE
DONALD TRUMP.
THE OPPOSITE HAS HAPPENED.
DONALD TRUMP HAS SHAKEN THIS
TIME.
WHAT IS TRUMP GOING TO DO?
HE'S THE BEST NEGOTIATOR WE
HAVE.
HE COMES THE TABLE AND TELLS
WHAT HE WANTS.
OF COURSE HE WANTS TO BRING
TROOPS HOME BUT HE WANTS ISIS TO
BE CRUSHED AND HE WANTS TO
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT THERETO
WHICH ISIS CANNOT EVER REAR ITS
UGLY HEAD AGAIN.
THE LAST ADMINISTRATION CREATED
ISIS.
THIS PRESIDENT WANTS TO END IT.